Que las extremas
derechas lleguen a los gobiernos no es 1 broma,
repercute en 1 agenda que es absolutamente regresiva.
Eso no quiere decir que todo debe ser aceptado,
pero sí creemos que hay que reparar al contexto
más que a los hechos puntuales.
Y el contexto es que en el estado español hay gente
muy interesada,
con mucho poder,
sectores judiciales, mediáticos,
sectores de la derecha y de la extrema derecha
por hacer descarrilar
ya no solo 1 legislatura
que se puede entender en términos de oportunidad,
tienen hacer descarrilar
debates que interesan a las gentes de nuestro país,
a las gentes de Cataluña,
las gentes de galiza, las gentes del estado español,
a las mujeres, a los jóvenes, a los trabajadores.
Yo espero y deseo
que todo el Mundo tenga en cuenta
que lo que nos jugamos
no es 1 votación, sino algo más.
No es 1 problema de legislatura o no,
es 1 problema de si somos o no coherentes
con 1 mandato masivo
que el Pueblo Vasco nos Dio,
en nuestro caso a nosotros.
Y es impedir que la extrema derecha llegue al gobierno,
porque eso es lo que está en juego